Readers,
readers typically finish the last books of paradise lost with,
I dunno,
I certainly had this experience the first time I read it and I think actually
many times since then,
um,
readers tend to finish the last books of paradise lost with something like a
sense of,
of,
of disappointment and the disappointment that is traditionally accompanied these
last books is usually associated with the question of their style.
Uh,
Michael's prophetic vision of future history is laid out before Adam with and
you and you get this sense of with kind of labored and painstaking didacticism
that we so Miss Raphael,
I think that the athlete will Raefiel had charmed us with that endearing
uncertainty that he had about the structure of the cosmos.
For example,
was Ptolemy,
right?
Was Copernicus right?
Who Cares?
Rafio made an art out of,
out of his uncertainty and he seemed to place his blessing thereby on all of the
ambiguities and all of the ambivalences and uncertainties that field nearly
every line of the poem.
But,
but everything or nearly everything,
nearly everything changes with the appearance of the Archangel Michael.
Michael speech is much less open.
There's,
this is,
there's no question to this,
to the prolife,
to a proliferation of signifying possibilities.
He speaks in labored declarative sentences and his purpose seems above all the,
to provide Adam with a,
a powerful,
powerful sense of his culpability.
Adam's culpability for the hell that is future history.
And I mean actually held quite quite literally because there's an important way
in which the last two books of paradise lost provides us with a kind of mirror
of the,
of the first two books,
the catalog of fallen history that we have at the poems.
Conclusion reproduces and rehearses a lot of the patterns of behavior that were
established in,
uh,
in the,
in the first two books.
And David's lecture on Friday has,
has made me think of the ways in which the sometimes what seems to be the
futility of human action and human behavior in the last two books also hearkens
back to an earlier time,
even before the events are accounted in,
books one and two.
And that's of course the,
the,
the war in heaven.
The pointlessness of the war in heaven on some level gets reproduced in the
sense that we have some times of the pointlessness of life after the fall in the
last couple of books of the,
of the poem,
but like the war in heaven.
Uh,
there is,
uh,
there is a kind of heroism that's possible,
in,
in the last two books of Paradise lost,
and I won't be talking about this in any length,
but it's an important part of Milton's conception of history.
And it's often referred to as Milton's one just man theory of history.
There's always,
every generation seems to have one man who is willing to stand alone and stand
apart from the corruption of the crowd.
And that man will do everything he possibly can on some level.
It's still going to be futile,
uh,
but to advance,
the civilization and the level of spiritual excellence of the people that much
further.
And that the one just man in the war in heaven was of course the angel ab deal
with whom Milton himself,
um,
was felt himself so identified.
Well in any case book,
think of book 10,
both 10 had been filled with the,
with the catalog of the punishments that Adam and Eve had to endure as a
consequence of their behavior.
But it seems at times as if the,
the harshest punishment of all,
um,
that comes as a consequence of the fall,
we'll be Adams subjection to the catechism of Michael in books 11 and 12,
Adam is subjected to an instructor and instructor who's,
who's grim sense of humor,
who's a brace of sarcasm,
who's unfeeling,
didacticism all contribute,
at least to my mind,
to a sensibility,
utterly foreign to that of the first 10 books.
And,
and if we,
as the sons of daughters of Adam and eve are to be punished,
um,
it,
it's,
it seems as if we too are to be punished,
uh,
for,
for that original sin.
And how are we punished?
Were punished because we have an obligation if we want to finish this stupid
poem,
we have an obligation to read,
um,
and experience Adam's uncompromising,
the Michaels uncompromising pedagogy,
his teaching of Adam.
Now the literary literary style of the last books.
Maybe that aspect of them,
that first first insights our disappointment,
but it's certainly not the only disappointing element of those.
Those books were also disappointed with the actual content.
I'm disappointed with the content of Michael's history.
You remember rent I and,
and,
and uh,
I will continually be hearkening back to,
to Raphael who seems so much more affable in retrospect than it may maybe he did
at the time.
Um,
we remember at raffles teasing account of a future history in,
in book five,
you'll remember this if Adam and Eve could only remain sinless,
if they could only remain obedient,
then their future might consist of that grand but slow transmutation,
um,
into the theory will matter of of angels.
It was really quite beautiful,
but Adam and eve of course did not remain sinless and their future history
necessarily has to look disappointingly different from that natural history
that,
that Rafio had,
had been able to anticipate.
Now,
most critics,
most Milton scholars writing about the last two books of Milton's poem have
invested their time and you can understand why this is necessary.
I have invested their time in defending books 11 and 12 and there's a certain
kind of nervousness about the unpleasantness of the conclusion of,
of,
of this poem.
And,
and critics are continually,
and I think this is misguided,
but I understand it.
And then the less they're continually attempting to shelter the poem from the
accusation that it's ending represents something like a disappointing falling
off.
Now I think these critics are right.
They're absolutely right to insist that the last books are supremely artful
creations that's undeniable.
And that Milton displays in them his sophisticated gay engagement of,
of Biblical history and end of theology.
Um,
it's an he,
Milton takes extraordinary care in crafting the process of the education too,
which Adam is subjected in the last books that said,
I think it's a mistake.
I'm convinced it's a mistake to deny the fact that these books are in addition
to all of that,
that they are disappointing and I,
and so I think we can profitably examine why it is that Milton ends his poem
with these last books.
Michael's severe treatise on scriptural history.
Now these last books,
Mark Milton's only attempt in paradise lost to represent what we would think of
as actual human history.
And in order to,
in order to understand why this section of the poem is so is so troubled and so
worrisome,
we have to understand Milton's own brush with history,
his own participation and the disappointing history of the failed puritan
revolution.
Now,
Milton has,
has,
has taken great pains to keep from his poem anything like a direct illusion to
the political turmoil of his own day.
But what I'm,
what I'm hoping I'll be able to do at least for a few minutes here is to show
how one of the ways in which Michael's treatment of script scriptural history is
still intimately connected to the contemporary political history that Milton was
himself and meshed in.
Now,
you may have noticed that the work of Milton's political pros that I have by far
that I have most consistently sided,
um,
over the course of these lectures is written little things on the board for
quotation of it is areopagite Jica that this speech against licensing that
Milton had printed in 1644 and there's a way in which the,
that exuberant liberalism of Area Reo Politica was continually reef surfacing in
the most interesting and a lot of,
in a lot of cases,
the most daring passages of the entire poem.
And W we,
we were,
we remember instances in which,
um,
Bilio entered another point eve seem to be actually alluding to area political
or certainly reproducing arguments that Milton had made there.
And so I devoted a lot of attention to Aereo politica but in doing so,
I think I've also distorted maybe kind of drastically the truth about Milton's
sensibility in the very years that he was,
he was writing paradise lost.
Um,
Milton's epic poem appeared over 20 Years,
23 years after the treatise on licensing in the mid 1640s.
Milton as an I,
and I've,
and I've given you a sketch of this history before,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's worth looking at a another time,
um,
in,
in the mid 1640s,
Milton was really at the height of what we can think of as his liberalism,
even,
uh,
even though that word wasn't yet an existence,
I'm,
Milton was wildly optimistic about the success of what he felt to be the puritan
revolution.
And he seemed genuinely confident that something like a rational spiritual
puritan utopia could actually be established on English soil.
And at the center of his political optimism was,
was his faith in the Political Pac,
the political category that Milton called the people.
And when he was writing in Latin,
he would use the Latin for people populace.
And throughout the 1640s,
um,
up to 1650,
Milton was confident,
really exuberantly confident that God had infused the power of reason and virtue
into every single human individual.
And that this God given capacity for a reason and virtue would enable the
English people,
the populace to govern themselves,
to govern themselves in an entirely [inaudible],
thorugh,
Terrian almost completely egalitarian political structure.
And you can see the,
I think you can see most dramatically,
and this is a treatise that we haven't,
that we haven't read in this course,
but it's included in the Hughes.
Um,
you can see this faith in the self rule of the people in Milton 1649 treatise
really the greatest of all of the what we call the regicide treatises,
the tenure of kings and magistrates in which Milton and actually actively
advocates they're regicide.
There's almost a sense in,
in the tenure of kings and magistrates,
um,
that you don't even really need any kind of form formal governmental structure
at all.
The people are actually going to be able to govern themselves without,
without any,
without any other edifice.
There turned out to be a problem.
However,
uh,
with Milton's political idealism and that problem,
no doubt involved.
The fact that Milton's political idealism seemed to have had no basis whatsoever
in reality.
And Milton may have been,
may have been,
uh,
convinced that God had infused every single human individual with this power of
rational self rule.
But the actual people,
the actual populous of,
of England,
um,
turned out not to be so easily convinced the real English people themselves were
considerably more conservative than the small puritan elite who had pushed for
the execution of Charles the first and 1649 and who had placed themselves at the
head of,
of the new,
uh,
non monarchic Republican government.
And if anything,
that the majority of the English people themselves were,
they were in favor of monarchy.
And so Milton found himself as so often compelled to modify his own political
idealism by 1650.
Milton wasn't able to say that the English should be governed by,
by,
by the people,
by 1651,
I should say.
He was no longer able to say that,
that the people obviously on some level that people obviously couldn't be
trusted any longer to get it right.
And so we had to weaken his claim that the people we're all rational and self
governing and he began to form or it a much less idealistic principle of
government.
And that was the government of England by a small elected body.
Um,
a small elected body of people called parliament and parliament had existed well
before,
uh,
this new turn in Milton's a political philosophy.
But Milton was placing an entirely new importance on this,
on this,
on this body.
So maybe the people themselves aren't all that rational and virtuous and self
determining capable of self government.
Uh,
but surely parliament,
this is the new turn in Milton's thinking and elite group of the people can be
counted on to uphold Milton's own value of,
of rational self determination and rational,
rational self rule.
Well,
there,
there were Republican decade wears on the 1650s,
and by the time we get to the,
the end of the decade,
the king lists government of England under the rule of Oliver Cromwell and later
under the rule of Cromwells son,
this Republican government is getting closer and closer to a complete collapse.
And there's a widespread popular movement.
It's a movement fomented by the people seeking the return of the Stuart
Monarchy.
And this time it's not only the common people,
um,
who were calling for the return of their king.
It's also parliament who has,
uh,
you know,
from Milton's perspective,
parliament has entirely sold out.
And so by late 16,
59,
there's a majority now even in parliament desiring this is again Milton's,
Milton's construction of it,
desiring to re subject the English people to the tyranny of monarchy.
And so in 1659,
when Milton is writing his final political treatise,
um,
he's compelled to alter his views once again,
and he finds very little evidence of the rational virtuous ethical principles
that he had been so confident about an area of Politica.
Um,
this,
this idea that all human individuals possess a,
the virtue and the reason and the spirit that he had previously attributed to
them.
And it starts to seem as if all men are actually not created equal.
And the very few of them have anything like divine virtue or divine reason
infused into them by God.
And so now the,
the,
the people that Milton had once so wonderfully and movingly idealized,
um,
he's able to refer to and it's really kind of jarring and just frankly,
it's depressing.
Milton's now able to refer to the people as the,
and I'm quoting here,
the rude and inconsiderate multitude,
the unruly mob.
You have a whole elaborate lexicon of invective concerning the people in the
latest,
the last political treatises of,
of,
of Milton's,
um,
the governing body that Milton Oh,
so,
so Milton imagines,
because he can't even count on Parliament,
um,
he comes to insist that the unruly and irrational English,
these masses are ungovernable even by parliament.
And so that this,
the governing body is going to have to be an even smaller group,
a collection of England's most rational,
most spiritual men.
Men,
of course,
you look exactly like John John Melton himself.
So a group,
a group of men,
more excellent than the much far too large mass of people that constitute
parliament.
And you have something like,
uh,
what's essentially a spiritual elite.
This spiritual elite,
um,
would have to govern England.
And Milton thinks of them as a council of saints.
He refers to them as a council of saints.
So in a little more than a decade,
this political idealist has,
has shifted from his celebration of the power and the liberty due to the people,
uh,
to a depressingly shriveled sense.
And it is,
it is pretty shrunk and it's a,
and it's a pretty pitiful thing,
a shriveled sense of the power and liberty due to only do to a very small group
of likeminded puritan revolutionaries.
So,
so a lot of the liberal confidence of a work like area politica just disappears
by the time we get to Milton's late political pros.
Um,
just how depressing this shift is,
um,
will become clear to you.
When have I have I assigned the ready and easy way to establish a true
Commonwealth on the,
on the syllabus.
I may have taken it off this year because I did not want to depress you,
um,
that you should not let my attempt to protect you from what might seem the
ugliest parts of Milton from taking advantage of fuses,
inclusion of that,
uh,
of that important and interesting text in the,
in your addition.
Um,
Milton will argue in their ready and easy way that he wrote in 1659 that this
new spiritual counsel,
the counsel of saints,
they should actually be employed.
Uh,
two,
they should actually be permitted to deploy military force,
deploy force if necessary to subject the unruly masses to their will.
This is how the argument goes and it's a disconcerting one.
The people are now so little to be trusted that they have to be forced to
recognize,
uh,
they have to be forced to recognize at gunpoint if necessary,
um,
that they,
that they must now be forced to recognize their God given liberty and their God
given capacity for,
for a self rule.
And of course it goes without question.
There's a,
there's a horrible paradox there.
Milton seems to be arguing that the people will,
will govern themselves.
God dammit,
even if there have to be forced,
even if they have to be forced to do it.
So this final plan,
this is Miele Milton's final political scheme is something like a polit,
a hunter of,
of Puritan Saints.
Of course,
the scheme was never enacted and shortly after Milton proposed it,
the Republican government,
I'm completely collapsed in early 16,
60.
And Charles the second the dead King Sun was returned to the throne and monarchy
was restored and Milton was.
And think about the position that he's in.
Melton was actually placed in,
in,
in prison for a while for his writings against the king and he was generally
living in,
uh,
in,
in some degree of poverty and certainly in disgrace.
All of this is a very long winded way of saying we have come a long way.
Um,
by the time we get actually to the composition of paradise lost,
we've come a very long way from the moving idealism of [inaudible].
Milton has endured an entire decade of,
of political disappointment.
And I think it's possible to see the real,
the,
the relation between the fall of Milton's own political idealism over the course
of a decade and a half or so.
And the fall of man as it's represented in paradise lost,
Milton's able to,
to use the narrative of the fall of paradise to in some way I think to map his
own experience with the loss of the English Commonwealth,
the English Commonwealth that Milton had really seen as something like a
paradise of,
of Puritan Saints.
So Adam,
you could think of,
you can think of Adam and eve after the fall,
um,
as in a lot of ways,
at least as a version of the English people for Milton in the late 1650s,
they show surprisingly few signs of internalized divine reason and internalized
virtue.
And so this is why,
at least I think this is why Milton has stirred to introduce into his narrative
this irritable arch Angel Michael.
And,
and this is why Milton stages this scene of angelics instruction so differently
from the way he staged the scene with Raffia oil.
Um,
and just,
I only need to mention eves role in all of this.
You'll even will remember decided on her own.
She decided on her own not to stick around for RAF lessons in astronomy.
She just as soon learn it,
she told us,
oh,
she just as soon learn it later from Adam,
who's pedagogy was a little more interesting than ELLs because Adam interspersed
his lessons with kisses.
That was Eve's choice and Milton goes out of his way to represent that as Eve's
choice.
But,
but after the fall,
eve is not given that choice.
She's forced to UB sent herself here and Adam who,
who gets to stay.
It's not clear that that's
what kind of privilege that is.
It Adam is subjected to the severity of Michael's teaching on some level because
he can't be trusted to behave as a rational self governing individual after the
fall.
Someone is going to have to teach him and in fact teach him quite forcefully how
to understand life in the fallen world.
And so Michael enters the,
enters onto the scene and he instills in Adam,
I think this is his goal,
at least to instill an atom,
the powers of reason and virtue.
And he does this by means of a history lesson,
something that before the fall,
Adam seems to have possessed instinctively or at least a kind of reason and
virtue that he possessed instinctively.
But now it needs to be instilled.
So Michael Presents Adam with the sweep of Christian history and with the
promise of Man's eventual redemption from,
from the fall.
And it's this entire lesson that Adam is going to have to internalize,
literally take into himself.
And the last two,
the last two books,
a paradise like Allston,
I think in a lot of ways represent something like a drama of internalization.
Uh,
one of the important aspects of these books is what they have to tell us.
I think about the complicated psychological process of,
of the internalization,
of any kind of authoritative wisdom.
So we're finally now in a position to actually look at the poem.
Um,
look at page four 42 in the Hughes.
This is a book 11 line four 11.
Michael history 11 a history lesson is,
uh,
is really quite extraordinarily,
carefully organized and it's,
it's,
it's broken up into d into two discrete sections,
books 11 and 12.
And these two discrete sections proceed along,
uh,
along entirely distinct line.
So the first half of the lesson which takes us up to the moment of God's
destruction of the world with Noah's flood,
um,
is presented to Adam as a,
as a vision.
And Adam sees this,
uh,
early history unfold itself.
This is something that comes to him through the,
through the access of his eyes.
Now,
the second half of the lesson lesson,
which is the entirety of the lesson as it exists in book 12,
is not presented to Adam visually at all.
Mike Lee,
since Michael simply describes it to Adam,
he relates it in the form of a narrative.
And this,
this shift from,
from vision to narrative has everything I think to do with the psychological
process of internalization that Milton is exploring in the last books in it.
I think it has everything to do as well with the shift in literary style too,
which Milton subjects,
the ending of his great epic that turn to the new style of books 11 and 12 is in
a lot of ways analogous to Michael's turn to d too,
didactic narrative in book 12,
after the Grand Tableau's after the all the visual splendor that he has
conjured,
um,
in,
in the,
in the visions,
the masks,
the,
uh,
the Tablo Vivo,
essentially that Michael presents to Adam and book 11.
And this new style is geared even more intensely toward the project of
internalization.
It places a greater and greater burden on Adam and certainly on the reader to
ascertain its significance.
Um,
so traditionally the truths of history could actually be seen,
but eventually by the time we get to book 12,
they can only be heard.
Adam has to become increasingly active in,
in his own education.
So,
um,
so let's look at the first.
Uh,
let's look first at the visionary aspect of,
of book 11.
I don't know what to do with this passage.
This is line for 11.
Michael Leads Adam them to the top of the highest hill paradise a hill.
So Hi,
um,
explained this to me that Adam can see the location of every great western city
that will come to establish itself in,
in,
in future years.
Um,
but simply seeing all of these locations isn't sufficient.
Michael's pedagogy has to be more thoroughgoing even than that.
And so we inspires Adam to see the actual scenes of history unfold themselves
before his eyes.
So this is what,
this is what we're told at line four 11,
but to nobler sites,
Michael From Adam's eyes,
the film removed,
which that false fruit that promised clearer site had bread then purged.
Michael having purged Adam's eyes with you for and rue the visual nerve for he
had much to see.
And from the well of life three drops instilled so deep,
the power of these ingredients pierced even to the inmost seat of mental site
that Adam now in forced to close his eyes sunk down and all his spirits became
entranced.
There's,
there's something about the ophthalmological specificity about this passage that
really gets me,
um,
of this account of what Milton is telling us was actually done to Adams eyes in
order to allow him to see the unfolding of Christian history.
The ingestion of the forbidden fruit seems to have weakened his eyesight.
And so the new,
the new film that has come to cover over Adam's eyes has to be purged with these
herbs.
You frizzy and room and Michael goes even further than that than that.
And ads for good measure three drops from the well of life in order to permit
Adam to see in his mind's eye sights impossible even before the fall,
that this scene of inspiration,
I think it's strange,
but it of course it has a powerful charge for us,
not not least because for so much of the poem,
the poet himself has claimed to be inspired and his composition of the poem,
and we know this,
Milton Milton was blind and he was convinced at something,
or at least this is the,
this is the William Kerrigan argument that I exfoliated for you all.
He was convinced that something that he had eaten,
had,
had on some level been responsible,
um,
for the vapper Russ film that seemed to have covered his eyes and the invocation
to book three.
You'll remember Milton bids,
the Muse Urania to purge him of that film,
all missed from thence purge and disperse that I may see and tell of things
invisible to mortals site.
And Nelson's clearly drawing a connection here between his own inspiration to
write paradise lost in Adam's preparation to witness the vision that is future
Christian history.
That much I think is that much is clear.
But what,
what exactly does this,
does this connection mean?
What is the relation between Michael's vision and book 11 and the inspired epic
poem that Urania the Heavenly Muse,
the heavenly spirit,
whatever we're supposed to call that entity that,
that this entity helps Milton to right there.
The relation,
I think I welcome other possibilities,
but I think the relations seems to be something like an ironic one and that
irony is suggested,
I think by the weird chemical exactitude of,
of Milton's description of,
of Adam's inspiration.
We have an actual scene of medically induced inspiration at the very moment that
the inspiration of the poem itself seems to have been lost.
That comes to a stop.
The,
the loss of innocence that has brought with it,
the loss of Milton's or what I think we were associating with and identifying as
Milton's inspired poetry and Milton carefully crafts his account.
I think of this,
this vision of poetry in a,
in a,
in a poetic style that can only with great difficulty be described as,
as inspired.
Um,
it's,
this is these,
these last two books are amazing works of art.
Um,
but we don't have anything like that extravagant and dramatic rhetorical
lushness that had so characterized the previous 10 bucks.
What you haven't book 11 is Milton's
enact meant in some way of the birth of what we can think of as modern modern
poetry,
a Po poetry that's been purged of excess and purged of all of that open ended
figuration.
Um,
think of the renaissance,
the,
the literature of Spencer and Shakespeare,
the renaissance called the amplitude of it's great writers.
Uh,
copia.
Um,
we,
we no longer have that Copia here in,
uh,
in the last two books,
we have a,
a poetics that is given to puritan austerity and simple declarations of moral
facts.
And,
and you will see that the poetic motive paradise regained.
And in fact the poetic mode of a lot of later poets.
I'm thinking of the discursive,
um,
the discursive poetry of a,
of a romantic poet like Wordsworth has been heavily influenced by the,
the last two books of paradise lost.
So Adam has to be chemically induced to see future Christian history because all
other inspiration in the poem is no longer is no longer operative.
Um,
Adam has to be compelled,
literally compelled to see how this history unfolds itself in the,
in the,
in the manner of little pageants and,
and,
and little skits.
He has to see it of course,
because he's,
he's not able at this stage in his development to understand it's important
through the non visual faculty of,
of,
of imagination.
And I think Milton,
the inspired profit has an incredibly,
uh,
and troublingly complicated relation to Adam at this point.
Adam,
who is so uninspired,
um,
in this poem that Milton has claimed to be so overly inspired to write in the
first place.
My guess is that the bond buying poet Milton is actually scornful on some level
of the fact that Adam has to be inspired merely to see the events a future of
future years.
Milton zone,
prophetic powers,
presumably entirely transcended the entire category of the visual.
Okay,
let's,
let's move on.
Look at the top of page four 46 and the Hughes.
This is book 11 line five 56.
This is Milton's description of the,
of the cities of the planes that the cities of the plain that Adam sees and the
emphasis is,
is everywhere in this account on,
on those things that can be discerned through acts of visual perception.
So line five 56,
he looked and saw a spacious plane.
We're on,
we're tensive various you buy.
Some were herds of cattle grazing,
others whence the sound of instruments that made melodious chime was heard of
harp and Oregon.
And here Milton goes onto describe the player of that organ.
This is the first human musician.
Presumably this is the first human artist,
um,
uh,
of any kind.
Um,
he hears the Chime,
but also,
uh,
who moved their stops and chords was seen his volunteer touch instinct through
all proportions,
low and high fled and pursued transverse the resonant fugue.
Now we might reasonably expect that Milton's one and only representation of a
human musician in,
in the poem,
I figure who's artistic touch is a lot like,
like,
like Milton's instinct through all proportions,
low and high.
We might expect that this would appear in a favorable context.
How,
why would we not?
But as in so many other instances throughout these final books,
Milton who has so absolutely become our stereotype of him as the,
he's the humorless Puritan,
um,
he's,
Milton is turning on,
he's really betraying the very art of sound that that constitutes one of his
poems,
greatest achievements.
Um,
there,
there has to be something self wounding here in this derogation of,
of,
of music.
And I don't care that it's fallen music.
Nonetheless.
This is beautiful music that Milton knows that he's representing here.
Uh,
but the beautiful music of the organism nonetheless inextricably linked to the
fall,
the organists fingers flee and pursue the resonant few just as Adam and Eve will
soon be fleeing paradise pursued of course by a band of armed Cherubim.
Like the beautiful sounds that are heard.
Beautiful sites that are seen are necessarily,
um,
unvarying Lee suspect in these books.
It's really not until books 11 and 12 that we get the full sense of just how
much of a,
uh,
of a,
of a surly Puritan Milton has,
has,
has become just how much of the suspiciousness,
the,
the general suspiciousness that the puritans had of the whole aesthetic
category,
how much of that he has adopted for himself.
Um,
look,
look down at line five 80,
these men on the cities of the plain long had not walked when from the tents.
Behold a bevy of fair women richly gay and gems and wanton dress to the harp.
They Sung soft amorous ditties and in dance love this phrase.
And I don't really know if it meant then what it means.
Now I'm to the harp.
They Sung Soft Amaris ditties and in dance came on and that wonderful,
uh,
the men though grave I them and let their eyes Rove rain till in their amorous
net fast caught they liked and each his liking chose.
So the faculty is a perception here are nothing more than the vehicles of,
of deception.
They're implicated in this endless replaying of the sexual seduction that is now
viewed mistakenly of course as the cause of the fall.
Um,
well,
uh,
dopey Adam here is still at an early stage in,
Michael's achingly long lesson in history and of course Adam thinks that things
with his descendants are starting to look pretty good.
Um,
and so that's what he tells Michael that the uh,
the top of page four 47,
this is line five 98
true opener of mine,
eyes prime angel blessed much better seems this vision and more hope of peaceful
days,
poor ten's.
Then those two passed.
And as so often,
and this is a,
is a pattern that will repeat itself until the book is done.
Adam has completely missed the point of Michael's lesson.
He mistakes the,
the pleasant appearance of this scene with,
with moral rectitude itself.
And so when Adam tells Michael Much better,
much better scenes,
this vision,
he's,
he's really no better than the men who live on the plane,
um,
who are eyeing the bevy of fair women and letting their eyes Rove without rain.
And it's the fact that this beauty is apprehended solely through the eyes,
solely through the,
the,
the senses.
That of course is that the lies at the heart of the danger here.
Adam has to learn to exercise his reason and this is one of the things that
Michael gets him to perform eventually.
So all things beautiful are by definition here suspect and this is one of the
lessons derived from I think the most elaborate of all of the classes that
Michael Offers Adam.
And that's the,
the history of the great flood.
Look at page four 52.
This is line eight 26.
This,
this story is so important that it's one that's actually narrated twice.
We have first the narrator's description,
um,
of the prophetic reenactment of the flood or it's like a,
not a reenactment of pre enactment because it actually hasn't happened yet.
This is the version that Adam actually sees and,
and then second,
we have Michael's long play by play accounting to Adam of what it,
what it is exactly that he has just seen
a line eight 26 of book 11.
This is the,
this is the narrated section of the story of the flood.
Michael Ism is describing for Adam the terrible rain that will undo all of the
work of the earth's creation.
All fountains of the deep broke up shell heave the ocean to USERP beyond all
bounds till inundation.
Rise above the highest hills then shall vis mount of paradise by might've waves
be moved out of his place,
pushed by the Horn,
had flood with all his verger spoiled and trees a drift down the great river to
the opening Gulf and there take root and island salt and bear
this line,
the haunt of seals and orcs and see muse clang,
the haunt of seals and orcs and see muse clang.
Michael's describing the effect of of the flood on Eden [inaudible].
This is the amount of paradise which like all other things will be moved out of
its place by the flood and washed into the open and Gulf of,
of the open of the ocean.
Now this particular image teaches us a lot more than the simple then simply the
extent of this mighty flood that the point here is the ultimate insignificance
of all,
all tangible things,
anythings,
anything whose beauty we had been appreciating by,
by,
by the,
by our senses,
Adam has been permitted by,
by an extraordinary administration of magic eye drops.
He's been permitted to see a scene of future history.
Whose point is the vanity,
the emptiness of all those things that that can be seen.
And the,
the,
the lesson is the lesson is absolutely devastating.
The Garden of Paradise,
who's lush vegetation,
who's wandering rivers.
We have had described for us in such powerfully visual terms and in such
powerfully seductive verse,
this garden will one day be pulled into the sea where it will take root and
island salt and bear the haunt of seals and orcs and see muse clang and,
and,
and the effect.
The effect here is not simply on our visual memory of the vegetative splendor of
Milton's paradise.
Nielsen's assaulting as well.
Our oral memory of,
of the sounds of paradise,
our memory of the beauty of the poetic verse that had produced in us,
our visual sense of the,
of the gorgeousness of the garden of Eden in the repressive puritan regime of
the last two books,
the Resonant Oregon tones of the poems earlier books also has to be,
they also have to be washed away.
And so in that amazing line,
the haunt of seals and orcs and see muse clang.
Milton creates an anemone,
anemone,
Amo poetic line on a Mo.
Okay.
It's automotive
and automotive poetic line.
Um,
what does it do?
It actually that with a kind of strident horror.
The,
the,
the squawking horrible sounds of of these sea creatures.
The,
the,
it,
it offers us a sonic emblem of the general stridency I think of the concluding
books that the uncompromising tone of severity that instructs us not to over
value the lush beauty of the,
of the previous books,
not to overvalue the beauty of paradise,
but also not to overvalue the beauty of the poetry of,
of paradise lost.
So Adam question,
uh,
well,
a question,
uh,
presents itself at this point and it's one that we have to,
when that I think is,
is inescapable,
why does even have to be destroyed at all?
Why is it washed away in Noah's flood?
We ask,
um,
the paradise that was lost,
it turns out,
wasn't the significant one.
This is an incredibly important part of mill Michael's lesson.
Look,
um,
look at how Michael explains this.
Atlanta eight 36.
Yeah.
Paradise is destroyed.
He's talking to Adam.
Paradise is destroyed to teach the,
that God attributes to place snow sanctity.
If none,
if none,
be that they're brought by men who their frequent or they're in dwell.
Now think of what Michael has just said.
The Garden of Eden will become an island salt and bear at least a thousand years
after the moment that Michael is currently relating.
This prophecy to Adam Eden will be destroyed in order to teach Adam in order to
teach Adam at this very moment in the present time that places aren't divine,
only the people that live in them.
This is an extraordinarily bizarre temporal disjunction that we have here at
Paradise.
Isn't going to be destroyed for another millennium or so,
um,
and in the time of Noah,
but it will be,
it will be destroyed in order to make good on Michael's prophecy
of its destruction,
paradise has to be destroyed so that Michael's prophecy of that event can have
its proper pedagogical effect on Adam.
Now in the present moment of the narration,
Michael Attempts,
it's an amazing way to compel the internalization of paradise by forcing Adam to
confront it's real life destruction.
Now at the conclusion of these lessons in history,
this is near the end of book 12.
This is page four,
67,
line five 85.
Michael States in a much more formal terms,
just this lesson of internalization.
Um,
so having listened to,
uh,
having listened to my history,
Michael Tells Adam then we'll,
they'll not be loath to leave this paradise,
but shall possess a paradise within the happier farm.
Once Adam pictures the terrible destruction of,
of paradise,
he'll come to understand that an internalized paradise is superior and it's a
happy compensation for the last place of,
of Eden and,
and,
and readers.
And Milton then certainly,
uh,
scholars of Milton have taken Michael at his word when he tells Adam that the
paradise that dwells within,
we'll be happy,
happier,
far than the,
than the paradise in which he himself is currently dwelling.
And we'll soon of course before still eve.
And there's an important sense in which we have to see the inward paradise as,
as the greater and more consequential miltonic phenomenon as a radical
Protestant,
Milton had always insisted on the superiority of,
of inward human reason.
And,
uh,
of the inward spirit over anything like the visual splendor of churches or the
sanctity of so called holy places or the written codes for that matter of the
written codes of church doctrine from a doctrinal point of view.
There's no question Michael is beyond reproach here,
but I still want to apply because this is what I do.
I still want to apply a little bit of a,
of skepticism to this,
to this little bit of dogma.
Um,
how convincing is Michael here?
Does our learning in one line that the paradise within us is actually happier
far?
Does it really undo our investment,
the reader's investment in this place,
this,
this paradise,
which has been so lovingly and so beautifully described and that thousands of
lines that that proceeded it when Michael describes the seals and orcs and see
muse clang that will literally take over the place of paradise.
Can we help it look back
with regret at the,
at the liberal beauties of this poem before this strident,
Archangel,
um,
had taken it over,
essentially taken the poem into receivership with his unyielding dogmatism,
a fee from the aesthetic point of view.
I think Milton's,
no,
Michael's discourse is,
is it complete disaster and we experience it as a form of loss.
And Milton compels us as readers,
I think to experience along with Adam and eve,
something like the loss of paradise.
We're compelled to undergo the loss of what we loved about paradise lost.
We are compelled to undergo the aesthetic fall that is taken by this very poem.
This is,
this is I think Milton's way of precipitating our internalization of his poem.
So as I mentioned earlier in the late 1650s,
Milton was no longer able to justify the extension of Polish political liberties
to the people the English people had.
To his mind they had,
they had fallen and Milton could no longer imagine.
Imagine granting the kind of the freedom of self determination that he had
described.
So rhapsodically in a treatise like [inaudible] and you can see a related
sensibility of,
of a hardening of sensibility really in the last books of paradise lost the
fallen reader,
the fallen poet.
Um,
we can no longer afford the moral and theological uncertainty that had been
fostered and really celebrated by the sublime poetic style that we can now call
now that it's gone,
we can now call miltonic.
It's as if we can no longer afford the indulgence and all of those stylistic
elements of the earlier books that have been so carefully purged from Michael's
lessons in history.
It's as if we can't afford to indulge in the,
those,
uh,
those ethically ambiguous similes,
the delectable illusions to the full range of,
of pagan classics though those extraordinary flights of the poems of the poets
own original myth making,
all of those elements that have made this poem so grand.
Um,
but that have continually,
as we've charted,
continually threatened to unhinge the story from anything like its basis in,
in moral doctrine or scriptural certainty that the poetic effect that we have
here is primarily one of,
of loss.
And it's a type of loss that we've encountered before in Milton.
And I'm,
I'm just about,
I'm just about at my conclusion,
but I want to remind you of Milton's first,
first poem.
His first great poem,
the Naitivity out of 1629 Milton,
you'll remember had described the triumphant entry of Christ and his and his
destruction of all of the evil pagan gods and the onset of the Christian era
was,
was celebrated as a joyous one.
But of course it brought with it a loss that Milton at that time was willing to
measure the pagan nymphs.
You'll remember they felt the pain of their banishment from the beautiful
forests of classical literature with flour in woven tresses torn the nymphs in
twilight shade of tangled thickets.
Mourn that that poem of religious celebration made a brief,
but it was a potent detour into log.
And Milton seemed almost to recognize the painfulness of the loss of classical
literature and lots of the poetic beauty with which we associate a classical
literature.
And I think there's a related sense of loss that attends the otherwise
triumphant conclusion of Milton's,
uh,
of the theological doctrine that Michael presents.
It that at the end of book 12,
uh,
on the,
um,
on the dock trinal level,
Michael does end on a,
on a painfully optimistic note.
I know that's an oxymoron,
but it's still brings me pain,
uh,
this the way in which he represents the promise of Man's eventual redemption.
But on an aesthetic level,
you have almost the plan.
GNC,
I think of LG,
a sad consciousness of all of those pleasures and all of those liberties that
now have to be forsaken.
Okay.
I'm ending the lecture there.
Um,
but I just want to to,
to remind you that that of course is not the end of the story.
That poem will change a final time,
uh,
once again in its last hundred lines or so.
Um,
you will have the reemergence of a lot of things that we associate with Milton.
and certainly we'll have the reemergence of the epic Simile,
which will pay attention to closely on Wednesday.
So focus for the next class.
On the poem's ending.